what's up what's up this is Nick bucks
neighborhood ho ho El Barrio East Side
check me out on the bootleg Cav podcast
so now let's go
bootleg cat podcast special guests
came all the way from New York City man
out here shooting music videos doing big
[ __ ] Nick bucks yeah what's up cat
welcome man thank you brother
representing Harlem yes sir uh for
people who don't know who you are man
kind of give me like a little background
and like obviously you're from Harlem
but just kind of how long you've been
rapping and kind of you know you've
obviously been killing it I told you you
had one of my favorite albums uh it was
like early 2021 your album drop right
like right after was it called I don't
know if it was quarantino right after
might be right after yeah but nah man
give everybody kind of a rundown man uh
just kind of your history books East
Harlem you know what I mean young spit
up you know one of the hardest from my
sides
um you know just real story real
authentic authentic music you know I
mean you know I [ __ ] with the people
yeah yeah I've been to uh East Harlem
once yeah no twice I got off on the
train at the wrong stop oh yeah I was in
Harlem and then I got off early or I got
off at the wrong stop to go see a girl
like I don't know 10 years ago so shout
out to Harlem and then I was out there
uh uh shout out to Bodega bands oh my
God yup El Barrio for sure he's
definitely a he's holding representative
yeah yeah yeah I go hard for that my
fourth to cut you over but I go hard for
the east side because you know when
people think about Harlem they think
about you know one area you know like of
course dip said you know 48th Linux but
it's bigger than that the East Harlem is
like our own little lane you know right
and it's like heavily like Latin
Community as well too right no it's
diverse it's diverse okay like Esau is
wherever you got Jamaicans you got
African-American you got Puerto Rican
you got Dominican right Mexican you got
we real diverse but we small but you
know we real diverse did you feel like
um because you know with the the rent
prices in Manhattan are so crazy it's
like insane sometimes I just get bored
and go on Zillow and just look at
apartments in New York just to see and
I'm like [ __ ] has there been like a lot
of gentrification in Harlem because it
feels like Harlem's still kind of like
an extension of Manhattan but it's
probably a lot more affordable a lot of
people been moving in in that area and
[ __ ] yeah no it is it is you know we got
um it's moles being built you know all
kind of things so you know when things
like that come into the community they
gentrify it you know I mean it makes
things more expensive 100 so like is it
becoming like a lot like least
affordable to stay in your own hood now
um yeah they got they got these new
buildings they got a lot of new
buildings being made you know like
um with a lot of amenities and stuff
like that so you know those are very
expensive yeah I see it changing uh how
long have you been rapping
um I've been I want to say I took raps
serious
like when I was 16 I've been rapping way
before that I fell in love with it like
when I was nine of course or what made
you fall in love with it
um G Unit you know Gina was like a big
influence to me um my dad used to sell
like old school music so when I was a
kid four three five years old he would
push me around while he sold this music
so he would tell like uh I love like
burnt CDs type [ __ ] he was so at the
time it was tapes oh cassette then CDs
came a little out that's what I used to
do that's how I got my name I used to be
at the swap meet with [ __ ] CDs
mixtapes all the Junior Radio [ __ ] so I
used to be [ __ ] getting it in so
definitely pirating a lot of people's
music back in the day before I was uh
anybody what year was that you said 2000
uh
040506 okay CD that's like when the CDs
come in I don't even remember I just
remember the transition the 90s the 90s
right yeah it was the 90s it was like
nah it might not have been the 90s it
was early 90s
yeah when I was a kid I had doggy style
on CD no I had it on tape but then I got
it on CD and like
yeah CDs was like mid 90s because I had
I bought uh like what what would you say
mid I bought a quemini from Walmart so
it's probably like 97 where it was like
kind of like the norm
it was like 96 97 98 it was kind of like
because I remember buying CDs
I don't remember many tapes but boys
demand
[Music]
um
yeah but look when CDs came out people
still kind of use cassette tapes yeah
yeah same thing with now people like
they're still people who have CD books
yeah listen I don't know who they are
they don't even make calls like you know
what they say uh country music still
sell CDs so if you go to Walmart ever
they still got CDs there but it's all
country yeah tough I don't know I think
some of them rednecks ain't smart enough
to figure out the streaming I mean it's
probably still money in there yeah my
car does not have a CD player 100 so
it's like what am I supposed to do with
this cities in the 80s
it was mid 90s it was mid 90s for sure
yeah because I had like a nice little CD
book in like 98. good time like tiny
little single page one you know what I'm
saying the CD CD book was crazy but my
pops had all that the worst part was
when someone broke into your car and
jacked your [ __ ] CDs that was like
you lost your life
you ever had your CD stolen no that's
before that [ __ ] man when you had this
like collection of music that you spent
all this thousands of dollars on and
someone got up in your whip and got up
under that seat and took your CD book I
[ __ ] make you want to kill somebody
bro
now we just got the whole CD books in
your phone
100 man hey we got to stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our newest
partner to the podcast shout out to our
family at hardean Las Vegas man listen
uh the number one dispensary in the
world I don't give a [ __ ] man craziest
dispensary with the most selection they
got so much weed in this [ __ ] place
you go to Las Vegas you're [ __ ]
feeling good with your homies it's
recreational you're like damn I could
just go into a store and buy weed yeah
but you just can't go into any store in
Las Vegas to buy weeds you know walk out
with some [ __ ] [ __ ] no you go to
hardine tell them I sent you all right
make sure you follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see it down
there you see the [ __ ] sweater
we represent and by the way can we shout
out
to them for sending me this this bootleg
head podcast
thingy
what is this called
no no it's uh for cigars
humidor yeah the humidor now this is
what's great about it we might start
doing this for our smoking guests
you know we might have to bust open the
Hardy and humidor
and just get into some of these treats
you know what I'm saying a little bit of
the treaties you know straight from
Hardy in Las Vegas even I mean
these are totally props because you know
they're props but with that being said
when you go to Vegas tell them bootleg
have sent you Jardin Las Vegas I'm
telling you it is like going to it's
like the Bentley of dispensaries it's so
nice the weed is the best the selection
is the best the bud tenders are the best
and yo make sure you shoot them a follow
Harding underscore Las Vegas go to
hardinglasvegas.com and when you're in
Vegas
go to hardine baby all right you already
know let's get back to the interview
um you uh I was telling you the album
that um I really got hit to you on was
uh the album you drive last year
neighborhood Hove uh crazy body of work
um appreciate it you got a new single
out with two chains obviously you just
shot a new video with whiz
um so I know you're prepping the new
album
um but talk about neighborhood hoe why
did you like why that title
um so you know when I said neighborhood
hole you know that's the impact I got on
my neighborhood you know the same how
big you know Hove is and what he mean of
course to the game also you know I I
Feel Like My Story related you know how
it was hard for him to kind of get a
deal you know they wasn't really
respecting what he had going on and how
he built this team and group of people
and just went crazy with it I mean I see
a lot of that in myself so that's why I
went with that what was um for you like
uh are you would you are you still
independent like what was your label
situation so I'm with my knock now you
know we I got um a project over at
monarch
um shout out to Monarch you know I mean
they you know taking care of me did you
find that it was like hard for you to
get a deal or get a deal that you like
were comfortable with signing because I
think like it you could if you have any
sort of buzz you could probably get some
sort of situation but the terms are
probably terrible right yeah that's yeah
you say you you said it the right way
like find a deal that fit me because you
know I did so much alone already so I
just wanted to make sure that whatever
situation come you know I mean they just
add on to what I had going on and it
makes sense as far as the business so
you were pretty much strictly
independent up until when
um I want to say yeah this this year
like recently [ __ ] what are the I mean
after that neighborhood was done through
distribution just distro yeah just
distro wow everything's been you know
alone what was the uh heart like you
know I feel like there's
gifts and curses to being fully
independent yeah more of your money but
you got to also work a lot harder you
got to work a lot harder and you know um
you just gotta you gotta yeah without
that machine you gotta you gotta do a
whole lot more and I mean I'm used to it
now you know I've been doing it so long
so that's a beautiful thing man
um who would you say where your biggest
influence is growing up you said G Unit
obviously for sure
um
um Dip set of course you know I'm from
Harlem
um yeah just just don't really Dipset
and Jew in it they're saying Junior
that's why I watched you know on TV so
if you had to
go with one
if you had to let's say you're on an
island you could only take all of the
Dipset discography or all the G-Unit
discography mixtapes included which
which CD book are you taking I'm not
going to be politically correct and say
hold on I got to go with G Unit because
you made me do it you gotta go Get Rich
or Die Tryin man beg for mercy you know
that's a whole lot beg for mercy was
crazy all the junior radios and you can
include the documentary from the game in
today because that was a juvenile album
yup I'll go for more Hunger for More was
crazy and even the Young Buck [ __ ] yeah
Buck was hard yeah now that I I go back
and I listen and my book was tough yeah
even uh the massacre I feel like gets
slept on of course there's so much good
[ __ ] records on there I feel like the
massacre was like somehow doesn't get
enough respect because it wasn't as big
as get rich or die trying but I'm like
yo there was some real Crazy Rap [ __ ] on
there ski mask way Baltimore love thing
shout out to [ __ ] position of
Power Man even the um
what was the disc record he had piggy
bank was hard damn that [ __ ] was hard
yeah 50 was flagrant back in the day
have you been able to meet him at all
yeah I mean every time I see if I take a
pic with him like it's the first time
yeah you know I just racked my 50 Cent
picks up well have you tried out for the
future oh no not yet I ain't even I
didn't even get a chance to really you
know kick it with him like how I wanted
to but every time I see him I left no
like yo you motivated me to do this [ __ ]
like real I let him know that every time
hey what up y'all bootleg cab here uh we
gotta interrupt the interview and tell
you about our family at Blue Chew look
if you go to bluetooth.com right now use
the promo code bootleg to sign up and
you will get your first month of blue
chew for free that's right they're gonna
give you the first month of blue chew
for free all you gotta do is pay five
dollars in shipping and you're gonna get
delivered right to your door some great
[ __ ] for your dick let me tell you what
it is all right if you're dealing with
erectile dysfunction if you're dealing
with any sort of stress and you just
need an extra little uh you know a
little performance enhancer if you will
all right for you Johnson down there all
you got to do is go to Bluetooth and use
that promo code bootleg and it's coming
straight to your door the same active
ingredient as Viagra as Cialis and then
the new mint chewable breaking news
there is a new mint chewable that blue
chew has just introduced to the
marketplace and it has the same active
ingredient as Levitra and stackson I'm
going to try to tell you about this
active ingredient it's VAR denafil
yeah I [ __ ] that up but try it out
supposed to be a little more potent than
the normal blue shoe whatever you need
regular blue chew the new mint chewable
whatever it is you're gonna knock it out
the [ __ ] Park all right look Barry
Bonds needed a little performance
enhancing when he uh hit 73 home runs
back in the day he holds the record
still you might need a little
performance enhancement in the bedroom
your lady will thank you your wife will
thank you your boyfriend will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're into we're not
judging over here at the bootlegate
podcast but I am judging you if you
don't go to Bluetooth right now and sign
up with that promo code bootleg and get
a month for free try it out it's
literally free all right let's get back
to the interview why do you think you're
slept on
um I think because you know there's no
gimmicks you know I mean I'm I'm what
you see is what you get you know I mean
I'm not trying to be in people's circles
right I'm not you know on everybody
lying about features it's like if you
respect what I do and you [ __ ] with me
then you know you're typing with me and
you know want to help me further what I
got going on so I just be mowing that
I'll be on my own Vibe help me under um
because I think in New York obviously
it's been a good year for New York hip
hop uh Joey Badass put out a great
project started really bad guys
um obviously the Griselda guys have been
going crazy Benny Conway obviously
that's not New York City it's Buffalo
[Music]
um but the drill scene is so big do you
feel like not being a drill artist right
now
and being from New York
has its like nationally do you feel like
it hurts you it's
um I don't think so I think that you
know what I do I build a kind of a fan
base all over you know I mean um I think
if this was probably like five years ago
and this was going on then maybe like if
I'm coming out and it's like oh you're
doing this right but I think I built
enough of a fan base you know in
different places that people still
support what I got to say you know I'm
100 uh what what is your take on the
drill scene because it's pretty crazy
man that's crazy a lot of Dope music but
also a lot of crazy [ __ ] like it's like
some serious like
man I'm like [ __ ] man these kids are
like really they don't hang out on their
records you know what I'm saying I mean
I embrace it I listen to it I love
because I'm a fan of music I'm a fan of
what they got going on I mean I feel
like I kind of play the role of you know
the middle when it comes to all that
stuff like I don't yeah cause you're
younger yeah I'm young but I got like a
real mature oh the show yeah you're like
somebody who the young kids could [ __ ]
with but also like if you're me and
you're an old head yeah yeah I can
appreciate it no for sure but I I played
I played the kind of the role of you
know embracing all of them you know they
a lot of them call me for advice and
yeah you know I mean they come to the
studio like you know I mean I play that
role with them so I embrace it I love it
I don't like the violence of course I
don't I don't like when it go further
than music because it's music but you
know other than that yeah shout out to
all the drill rappers yeah that's
important um who all do you have on this
new album I mean two chains and whiz
yeah we went heavy on this one um
we got two chains where is CeeLo CeeLo
Green CeeLo Green yeah we went got
Shield yup um tank shout out to town I
mean Ivory Scott one of the most
talented you know people in the game
um am I missing anyone
oh yeah Benny Benny Chef yep
yeah whoa shout out to um darrenjo on
the beat too it's hard for sure shout
out to Benny man I got you know every
time I get on platforms I gotta shout my
guy out he took me on tour with him you
know I mean getting a chance to you know
get off the block and share my talent
with the world Benny and his team are
great yeah shout out to Jake shout out
to Tony dinero shout out to my cops
those oh my gosh so you were on the road
was Tony dinero on the road with you
Tony Dan there that's my brother yes
that's my life Sony is just so yeah
that's my God man I could go on and on
he's the kind of guy I like yeah we
party together that's my girl you know
what I'm saying we always have fun
together and he don't hold nothing back
any opportunity yo I got this
opportunity for you bro very unselfish
yes the whole crew is super fire shout
out to Benny shout out to them and uh
yeah uh so Raekwon
Benny you Derringer be self me wow yeah
I gotta hear that yeah we're gonna put
it over here crazy how did you end up
working with uh whiz
um so um shout out to hit maker you know
him and um hit got a relationship um I I
had this song and I told her I'm like yo
where's it sound crazy on it so he
called him we just got it done no
problem and when I finally got a chance
to meet with you know I mean it was love
we clicked instantly he [ __ ] with my
vibe I [ __ ] with his and that's my guy
tried to hit maker uh he produced a song
yup yup
um yeah the executive person so he's
executive producing yep wow that's big
it's heavy that's super big how did that
end up happening he's a great guy too
shout out to him yeah I mean man hit
make is one of the most you know hardest
working producers I've ever seen in my
life you know he pushed me to work hard
for sure you know I mean he don't I I
thank him every chance I get here don't
allow me to say thank you man get here
with that [ __ ] but I'm thankful shout
out to him [ __ ] hey what up y'all gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
family at Odd Socks that's right go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg that's right bootleg
you will save 20 off at checkout now
listen we know that they have amazing
socks these are sour patch kids socks
these are hot Cheeto socks
Half Baked you know what I'm saying and
uh you know for those that like Snapple
so much so that you would wear socks
with snapple's logo on them and all my
Naruto fans they have the Naruto but
let's bust these boys out you know they
they got the underwear and the underwear
are crazy love the draws what do we have
here
oh oh we have we have Hey Arnold
underwear
these are [ __ ] amazing Jesus I'm
gonna wear these you know why I'm gonna
wear those oh because I have
Hey Arnold socks on you see what I did
there yeah that's right we out here
representing Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world I promise
you if you get your Odd Socks Basics
like these these are the basics right
those are uh I mean you're not going to
get any better than that you know what I
mean the odd Sox Basics are incredible
all right so uh that's my favorite I'm
always wearing a black or white pair of
Odd Socks Basics but uh don't like
listen to me try them out for yourself
go to oddsoxofficial.com use the promo
code bootleg save 20 off at checkout and
what was the initial uh introduction
with y'all like how did that so so um
Billy Billy manages me he also manages
hit oh that's perfect yeah so it was
just like us like the same thing with
Wiz me and hick clicked or automatically
been worked from the first day I met him
yeah and he just got some big records on
him at all times and producer of the
year for sure
oh yeah that's real that's I'm surprised
he didn't try to get you over to the
make it sound imprint I mean yeah we
that's family I'm I'm in I'm in here
make a sound I'm in yeah
crazy album together
would you say that like having him
involved kind of like put you in a
position to maybe have more commercial
records on this project yeah so that's a
that's a conversation I have like you
know even with my brothers on the block
or with my manager I feel like this
project right here was those songs was
the big songs
um you know you heard my music I'm more
of a I do it for the streets you know
what I'm saying I love real rap but you
kind of had them records you know I'm
saying if you don't have them records
you gonna be doing one thing I mean Jay
had those records on his albums
everybody had you know so that's what
this project is this project gives them
records it's letting the world Know I
Can Make Music you know I mean I mean
dude get Richard I try and head in the
club and [ __ ] 21 Questions 100 yeah
just that yeah so you feel like this is
kind of like your level up my level up
100 bigger beats you know I mean um
great features musically it sound good
my Cadence everything sounds well I feel
good about it do you have the name of
the album yet
um yeah blessed to the max you the first
one I know that though I ain't say this
yet so the name of my album is called
bless to the max that's dope I like that
why that title man cause I'm blessed you
know yeah I got um a bullet in my head
you know I'm able to survive I'm still
here
um
blue hell after hell losses after losses
the people you know I mean I've been
through a lot this year so we blessed it
I didn't know you got when did you get
shot
um 2011. [ __ ] yeah how old were you
you're like a kid I want to say like 17
[ __ ] 17. yep so what what happened man
um I want to say it was like the wrong
place wrong time you know sometimes it's
all you know yeah like different
energies colada you know it was it was
just the wrong place at the wrong time
so you got shot in the head and I had
well didn't go to the hospital for every
time I tell a story people think I'm
crazy she got shot in the head didn't go
to the hospital then because I didn't
know I didn't know I was shot I thought
I got Grace So a couple years after
um I figured out I had a bullet in my
head so I lived like three years with
the bullet in my head before I found out
so that's to the max bro for sure how
did you find out that the bullet was in
there so like I I was still in um school
I was having these like sinus problems
and [ __ ] my head was killing me yeah so
I went to go get the sinus checked out
you know they give you the MRI right and
they told me like yo you got a like a
piece of metal in your head maybe that's
where it's coming from but yeah and I
didn't fix it no no no no no no because
it was the sinus issue this wasn't
bothering me my bullet wasn't bothering
me it was the sinus issue so when I got
the meds for the sinus the pain went
away but I still got the bullet in my
head that's how I discovered it yeah
it's still here oh man it can't go
nowhere it don't make sense to take it
out right yeah because it'll stop
[ __ ] things up
clear bro Blaster than Max how did your
parents like feel when they found out
that there was like I'm sure they knew
about the incident but like I mean they
thought it was Grace so I went I went
home to my stepmom I put some like
bacitration
you know what I mean little ointment on
it and I went on about life like we
nobody knew right when we found out it
was like oh that's crazy yeah well yeah
yeah I feel like uh if you were
I feel like a lot of rappers would just
be talking about that all the time yeah
yeah I mean yeah for me there's not
nothing to glorify it is it is I'm
blessed I think of course every day but
being shot in I ain't trying to use that
as you know I mean I just think back to
50 and we all knew he got shot nine
times we did we did have you I mean I
know pop smoke did a many-man remix but
have you thought about like kind of I
mean you kind of have a pretty crazy I
think little TJ just did many men too oh
he did a freestyle yeah yeah yeah okay
going to Don Q or whoever I don't know I
think yeah yeah I think they was dissing
each other on that yeah and both I mean
Don Q's can really rap the TJ's hard too
yeah shout out to them guys man yeah hey
we gotta stop the interview real quick
tell you about our partners at my bookie
that's right salute to the family at my
bookie all right it is so much action to
get in on right now in sports we got the
playoffs in baseball we got NFL action
every Sunday and NBA season is upon us
yes if you want to get in on the action
and make some of this money with me I'll
be gambling all damn day I might have a
problem with that being said go to my
bookie right now when you sign up use
the promo code bootleg and they will
match your deposit all right that's
right your first deposit when you sign
up with a new account when you use that
promo code bootleg they're gonna match
it all right that means if you put in
500 bucks you get another 500 for free
to gamble with yeah all right I'm loving
uh some of the Futures too uh I love the
over on wins for the Sacramento Kings
and the NBA season coming up I think
they're going to have a good year I'll
also beta over on the Phoenix Suns
they're gonna have more than 52 and a
half wins what are we talking about plus
NFL action every Sunday let's get this
money go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg all right
when you do that they're matching your
first deposit off the rip no matter how
big or small let's run that [ __ ] up go
to my bookie right now use that promo
code bootleg and get your first deposit
matched free money to gamble with with
my bookie let's get back to the
interview like do you feel like
sometimes uh have you ever had like
found yourself in the middle of like
being friends with two people who have
problems with each other yeah I stay
away from all that man I got we got I'm
I got my own problems man I don't be
trying to get into nobody situations
thing I ain't got nothing to do with me
over some rap [ __ ] that is the right
approach for sure I don't know Rapture
this is music yeah the problem is is
like usually that happens and you should
be in the middle and be like hey look
y'all this is on some rap like you said
it's not some Street [ __ ] no yeah but
certain things you just certain things
you just stay out of you don't you know
you don't want nothing to do it and I'm
not God yeah certain things I just don't
want nothing to do it would you say
Obviously you have the rayquan Benny
record is there enough on this album for
the fans who really [ __ ] with you for
the street [ __ ] for the for the rap and
[ __ ] to really kind of appease them I
mean I got a few I think I think
I think so yeah I think so that's
something I was going back and forth
with about my project but I feel good
about it I think so
is it uh do we have a date yet not yet
no yeah do we got a date
November 18th okay almost two years of a
wait right yep yeah sure for sure [ __ ]
so you've been working man are you gonna
make everybody wait that longer for the
for the the next time no I got to keep
gas enough yes I gotta show I got to
show them what's going on 100 what is
something um for you man like obviously
uh
kind of had to do the independent thing
what would be some advice should we give
artists who are in a similar situation
as you being independent having to do
everything yourself that you mean I feel
like never stop you know I mean you got
to stay consistent you can't stop you
got to keep going I mean just
discouraging you know it comes being
discovered happens but you got to keep
going do you think do you think uh there
was ever a point in time where you would
hit like a low in your career it made
you kind of reconsider whether or not
you wanted to really do this rap [ __ ]
yeah I mean it's it's gonna be plenty of
them nights you have plenty of those I'm
pretty sure with whatever you do but
yeah I had plenty of those nights but
you know I kept pushing and I'm here
let's go man yeah uh anybody else from
uh Harlem that you want to shout out any
East Harlem rappers that you feel like
yeah four records man shout out to Papa
man is that your label yeah so you got a
label you sign an artist yep yep for
sure I know how to launch it soon okay
if you got one artist already nah but
that's who I'm working with closely dope
yeah yeah yeah what's up with Bodega
bams man oh shout out to buddy man I've
seen um his team I see um hola hola's
brother my man Luca um are the same
person they're the same person I want to
work with beams like he's one of the
guys who you know motivated me to do
this I told you he from the east side of
Harlem so see him somebody strictly for
my Poppy's album was so [ __ ] raw man
I gotta I got a chance to you know move
around with them when it was in New York
City a lot of times yeah and I love what
you know what they did obviously and
doing still as an ASAP crew tapped in
with you at all Rocky my brother that's
my guy yeah yeah that's my brother well
look the album's come in November 18th
November 18th blessed to the max blessed
to the max new single with uh with Wiz
is coming it's coming soon two change
records all right mask up is out now
make sure y'all go get it or streaming
platforms the videos out as well boom yo
go follow
of course man